fools rush in where angels fear to tread
a leopard doesn't change its
spots never trouble trouble until
trouble troubles you
from little acorns mighty oaks do grow
[Music]
helps those who help themselves
where there's a will there's a way
[Music]
a ship in the harbor is safe but that's
not what ships are made for
[Music]
it's darkest before the dawn
[Music]
always put your best foot forward
[Music]
when one door shuts another opens
good things come to those who wait
take it with a grain of salt
bitter pills may have blessed effects
there is no time like the present
an empty vessel makes a lot of noise
don't make a mountain out of a molehill
grief shared is made lighter
an idle mind is the devil's workshop
time and tide wait for no man
honesty is the best policy
an ounce of protection is worth a pound
of cure
hope for the best prepare for the worst
a thing begun is half done
if it ain't broke don't fix it
barking dogs seldom bite
if wishes were horses beggars would ride
be slow in choosing but slower and
changing
if you can't beat them join them
you can't teach an old dog new tricks
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
it's better to be safe than sorry
beggars can't be choosers
[Music]
it's easy to be wise after the event
the best things in life are free
it's never too late to mend
[Music]
better to be poor and healthy than rich
and sick
it's no use crying over spilled milk
better to wear out than to rust out
[Music]
learn to walk before you run
practice what you preach
the coward dies a thousand deaths the
brave but one
discretion is the better part of valor
[Music]
let sleeping dogs live
don't bite off more than you can chew
look before you leap
[Music]
don't bite the hand that feeds you
necessity is the mother of invention
don't cast your pearls before the swine
[Music]
no pain no gain
don't count your chickens before they
hatch
[Music]
no news is good news
you can't judge a book by its cover
once bitten twice shy
every cloud has a silver lining
one man's trash is another man's
treasure
[Music]
every man is the architect of his
destiny
[Music]
the pen is mightier than a sword
familiarity breeds contempt
persuasion is better than force
[Music]
all that glitters is not gold
practice makes perfect
all's fair in love and war
adversity and loss make a man wise
silence is half consent
a fool and his money are soon parted
slow and steady wins the race
when the going gets tough the tough get
going
a journey of a thousand miles begins
with a single step
[Music]
still waters run deep
a chain is only as strong as its weakest
link
the best laid plans often go awry
[Music]
a bad workman always blames his tools
the harder you work the luckier you get
a bird in the hand is worth two in the
bush
the proof of the pudding is in the
eating
there is safety in numbers
absence makes the heart grow fonder
[Music]
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions
[Music]
actions speak louder than words
[Music]
too many cooks spoil the broth
a drowning man will clutch at a straw
[Music]
watch the donut not the hole
[Music]
what goes around comes around
[Music]
give them an inch and they'll take a
mile
[Music]
you